Happy Valentine's Day.
Let's talk about making
babies, shall we?
I think it's about time.
♪Fun science,
fun science♪
♪Fun science is the
science of fun, yeah♪
So personally, I find
reproduction to be just
one of the most irresistible topics
to learn about in science.
I think this is for a
couple of reasons.
One: because I'm a human
and humans like to reproduce.
We're pretty good at it too,
but also because so much of reproduction
is just so incredibly weird.
The variation of mad and wonderful
and disgusting methods
that organisms on this planet
use to reproduce is so vast,
but every single different possible
type of reproduction
that exists on this planet fits
into just two different groups:
asexual reproduction
and sexual reproduction.
Asexual reproduction is the
method whereby the offspring
is an exact genetic copy of
its parent, a clone basically,
and this can happen in a
number of different ways.
There's fission, where the
original organism grows
and splits itself into
two separate organisms.
This is what bacteria
use to reproduce.
There's budding, where a large organism
creates a little bud on its surface
with the correct genetic material
in it that then breaks off
and grows on its own.
It's how yeast reproduces.
And then there's also
vegetative reproduction,
where you take a
cutting from a plant,
plant that cutting
in the ground,
and let it grow into
its own organisms.
Sexual reproduction,
on the other hand,
the one that you're
probably more familiar with
is where two cells from
two separate organism,
a male cell and
a female cell,
combing and grow to form an offspring
that has a mix of genetic material
from both of its parents.
Mad sex. Oh yeah.
For most people, though, the interesting
bit doesn't seem to be the cells
and their genetic codes,
but it's the method
by which these two cells are
allowed to meet each other.
In humans, just as it is
in many other animals,
a male makes a
bunch of male cells,
inserts them into the female
using the pair of sexual organs,
a single male cell fertilizes
a single female cell,
and a baby grows inside the
female until it's ready to pop out.
However, in no way is this the
"normal" method that nature uses
when it comes to
sexual reproduction.
It's just the one that we are most
familiar with, for obvious reasons.
Take the seahorse,
for example.
In this case, the female inserts
her eggs into the male
and then the male fertilizes
them and incubates them
and eventually gives birth
to them all by himself.
And then there's
the mountain slug
in which there aren't any males
or females, just hermaphrodites,
which means that every individual has
both male and female sexual organs.
In this instance, two slugs hang
off a tree branch together
by a string of
their own slime,
release their sexual organs
from behind their heads,
and then fertilize each other
for about an hour or so
before biting each
other's sexual organs off.
And actually, even though some
plants reproduce asexually,
some of them reproduce
sexually as well.
In fact, the flower is actually a
plant's sexual organ
with both the male and
the female parts inside of it.
But the variation
doesn't stop there
because there are actually
some animals that have decided
to start reproducing
asexually as well.
Like there are certain
types of shark and lizard
that have just given
up on men entirely
and just have
babies anyway.
And, yes, those babies are exact
genetic clones of their mothers.
It actually raises quite an
interesting question,
which is that if there are animals in the
world that can reproduce asexually,
why do men exist?
Why am I required?
And with that, why does
sexual reproduction exist?
What is the point of it?
Well, fortunately, the answer is
relatively simple and it's this:
sexual reproduction allows
for more variation.
It means lots of different organisms
with lots of different traits,
which, in turn, mean a
higher chance of survival.
Imagine, for example,
that all of a sudden,
the whole world just
got really, really cold.
If you were an organism created
by asexual reproduction
and you couldn't handle the
new weather, you would die,
and not only that,
but every single other individual
in your entire species
would also die.
However, if you are a species
produced by sexual reproduction,
although some of
you will probably die,
others may have nice
thick skin or big furry coats
or they might be smart
enough to make a fire.
They have the extra traits
that allow them
to adapt to the environment around
them and continue to survive.
And that, I think is why we are so wired
to be so fascinated by reproduction,
to think that it's so important,
to think that it's something taboo,
something that's awkward
to talk about,
something that we have created
whole ceremonies surrounding
because it is the thing that
has allowed us to evolve
and exist in the
first place, to survive.
Nature just prefers sex,
and frankly, so do I.
Should I have
done the wink?
I can always cut it out.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
CHARLIE: I made the room pink.
Do you want to...
Yeah...
Video making.